One of the reasons they excluded means I
cannot enter. They didn't ban me. Banned
in UK means my lecture cannot be
telecast. My video cassette cannot be
sold. My books cannot excluded means I
am not congenial to society of UK. So
I'm not allowed to enter but my video
cassettes can be sold and books can be
sold. My programs can be seen. So they
excluded me. And 10 years later in 2019
before that what does Allah do later on
Terza May becomes the home from home
secretary she becomes the prime minister
because there's so much infighting in
the party
that she is the black sheep she becomes
the prime minister
and when she become the prime minister
there is so much of problem in the
government she has to resign and she
cries
in front of the public.
So Allah humiliated her.
They planned and plotted Allah to plan.
And what happens
in 2019, 10 years later, Priti Patel,
Priti Patel is a UK national of Indian
origin. She becomes home secretary. Now
she's in place of Terresa May. when she
comes when she becomes home secretary in
July 2019 within a short span of time
she gives the statement we will
terrorize all the criminals of UK so now
she becomes a terrorist the home
secretary of UK IS NOW A TERRORIST GOOD
OR BAD if she's terrorizing the if she
terrorizing the criminals it is good so
when I say Muslim should terrorize
the criminals I become
a terrorist when she says she's home
secretary. She's being praised. Very
good. Very good. Double standard. So
Allah
makes it happen. She maybe she saw my
video cassette because she's she's of
Indian origin Hindu. Priti Patel Indian
origin UK national become the home
secretary. Maybe she saw my video. Very
good. So she gives the statement which
comes headlines in the UK place in the
UK papers that we will terrorize the
criminals of UK that means she wants to
terrorize she's become the terrorist now
these are double standards now many
times two different labels are given for
the same activity of the same indivision
two different labels for example before
India got its freedom more than 75 years
back there were many Indians
who were fighting for the freedom of the
country. Now these people by the British
government they were called as
terrorist. But the common Indians we
called these people as freedom fighters.
We called them as patriots. Same people,
same activity, two different label. Some
people are calling them terrorists. Some
people are calling them as patriot.
Freedom fighters. Same people, same
activity. If you agree with the view of
the British government that they had a
right to rule over India, then you'll
call these people as terrorist. But if
you agree with the view of the common
Indians that the Britishers came to
India to do business, they have no right
to rule over us. Then you'll call these
people as freedom fighters. And one of
the famous freedom fighters bakut Singh.
The British government called him a
terrorist and hanged him. We common
Indians. We called him Dbak. A patriot,
a freedom fighter. Same person, same
activity, two different label. Some
people are calling him hero. The
Britishers are calling him a villain.
Therefore, I told you media can convert
black into white, day into night, hero
into a villain, villain into a hero.
Same people, same attitude. And you have
number of examples. We know in 1775
when the Americans were fighting for the
freedom against the British, the
Britishers were ruling USA before USA
was formed. was ruling over America and
there were many Americans who were
fighting for the freedom. In 1775,
George Washington at that time by the
British government, he was called as
terrorist number one in the world. Later
on when Americans get their freedom and
they make USA United States of America,
the same terrorist number one George
Washington becomes the president of USA.
Imagine terrorist number one becomes the
president of USA. One country is calling
him a terrorist, the other country is
calling him freedom fighter. And both of
them then get together. Now they are
terrorizing the full world. UK and
America put together and they say that
we are we have the maximum human rights.
We fight for human values. This is
nothing but a show. They attack
countries which are less equipped for
money. And they're saying we going there
for peace. War for peace. They are war
on peace. Attacking Afghanistan, one of
the least equipped country in the world
for 20 years. What does Allah do? Turns
the table. after spending trillions of
dollars they had to retreat. They were
mujahin the real jihad the Talibans they
trained them they spend millions of
dollars in training them against a proxy
war against Russia but then when they go
to take over Afghanistan they don't
allow them who are you they don't allow
them and 20 years they fight Taliban
which are least equipped Allah helps
them they had to flee the country after
spending trillions of dollars